[Music]
[Applause]
nina kimes
dog lover herself the nfl analyst senior
writer podcast host tv contributor
uh meenakim show with lenny a weekly
podcast about football
and more and meena joins us now good
morning mina
hi good morning um i got a question to
start out with and it has
something to do with the end result of
this season that is i'm going to give
you all the quarterbacks who were 33 and
older
or all the quarterbacks who were younger
than 33.
russell wilson turns 33 this year so
he's in the older category
you can have all the quarterbacks who
wins the super bowl the younger
quarterbacks
this year or the older ones
um i'm gonna go younger as long as
patrick mahomes
is in the league i gotta go younger what
did you take away from the schedule
as far as what who the networks is there
a team where
they're looking at somebody that maybe
would be a surprise team this year based
on what the schedule showed
well i i would say actually this is not
what you asked but i i thought it was
interesting that the packers got five
prime
time games i don't know if the network
knows anything
we don't know you know about whether or
not because
gosh without aaron rodgers that would be
uh
quite a quite a load for jordan love to
be on prime time
that much um but no i i was surprised
actually not to see more brown's
chargers than prominent spots because
those are two
kind of young exciting afc contenders
uh and yeah clearly the networks didn't
agree we saw some ravens though
what about the bears and at what point
is justin fields going to be the
starting quarterback
you know i i've been saying loudly maybe
a little too loudly on our network i
would start him week one but they are
playing the rams obviously in that
sunday night opener and that is
a challenging defense to throw him to
uh at start that bear's offensive line
against aaron donald is not a pretty
formula i could see them waiting three
or four weeks but
you know with matt maggie's job on the
line and that offensive line and andy
dalton in place i don't see it lasting
long
how much of an improvement is the
quarterbacking position for the rams
it's pretty significant um you know the
the
downfield element that stafford brings
to the game has been so
lacking with jared goff and you know
it all sort of came to a head at the end
of the season when
it really became clear that sean mcveigh
would rather
start his backup from the aaf john
wolford
um who i love these preseason games i
called but he there was
it was curiosity right that jared goff
wasn't playing even though his injury
was dubious but i think that was
something that was brewing all year
frustration with scoffs ability to
create
outside of the pocket his lack of
accuracy throwing the ball downfield
his propensity turn it over over the
middle and i think
magic stafford is a massive step up for
them
but do you have the chargers and rams
both as contenders
i do i i feel like every year the nfl
media is too high on the chargers and
every year we get
slapped down um and and i know justin
herbert is like a prime regression
candidate you know being
that sort of hot rookie season that came
out of nowhere but he was playing behind
one of the worst offensive lines
in football our pass passlock winrate
metric has them as the second worst in
the nfl worse than the bengals who we
talk about like joe burrow was playing
behind wet paper towels
and they upgraded incredibly uh along
the line like clearly poured a ton of
resources there adding corey lindsley
best center available rashad slater
doesn't hurt was fantastic last year
under pressure
imagine how good he'll be with some time
in the pocket and knock on wood
derwin james coming back so i'm very
high in the chargers
are the cardinals a hot team there's
always that like three or four teams
that go
you know from sort of nowhere up to the
top make the playoffs or they go from
last to first
where do you stand on cardinals i'm not
as high on the cardinals as
others particularly because they play in
the post-apocalyptic hellscape that is
the nfc west but also
um there's still massive issues with
this team
in the secondary i think that they
didn't add enough playmakers to take
some of the heat off of deandre hopkins
with all due respect to aj green who i
think is in the over 33 crowd or plays
like it at this point
i i think rather than calling him the
hot team i would say cliff kingsbury
should be on the hot seat because he
came into this league
as a sort of questionable hire the
cardinals offense went from the worst in
the nfl to
average and i think he really benefited
from that comparison but last year
they regressed kyler murray didn't take
a leap forward
as a passer it really brought a lot to
the game with his legs and in my mind
if he doesn't kyler doesn't take another
step forward in his development this
year
i would be really i if i was a cardinals
fan
i would direct my ir towards clicking
furry we're talking to media climbs you
can uh
watch her with dan arlovsky marcus
spears laura rutledge
on nfl live every weekday at 4 eastern
on the mothership
when russell wilson came on our show and
then the fallout after that subsequently
did did seattle address what they needed
to address
or did russ get did he hear what he
needed to hear
that's right it's you that i have to
personally blame for three weeks of
debate hell being especially oh nina how
do you feel about losing your
quarterback
um i provided content for the media for
a month mina and no one thanked me
i'm okay you know what thank you it
wasn't like a moment in the year when we
really needed it like right now aaron
rodgers
basically single-handedly saving the
sports media industry and we should all
be
seeing hosanna's and his name and um
you know he is carrying us because you
know i'm on an nfl show dan
every day uh one hour a day
june is the desert and aaron rodgers is
pouring this water into our mouths he is
an oasis
for us and and you did do that with
russell and i i suppose i do owe you
some thanks for that even though
personally it caused me great
great emotional distress but candidly i
never thought he was leaving
and i also think that um he seems
to be pretty satisfied with what
seattle's done you know going out
training for gabe jackson
from the raiders to shore up the
interior of the offensive line uh
signing gerald everett's tight end
from the rams i thought that was he was
previously with the rams i thought that
was a sneaky good signing and then
drafting a wide receiver
a real speedster dwayne eskridge with
their first pick in the draft all really
smart picks but for wilson you know when
you look at the struggles
at the second half of last season it
wasn't because of the lack of
protection it was really schematic and
some of it frankly had to do with wilson
himself
so that's what i'll be watching for with
seattle early on to see if they've
if new offensive coordinator shane
waldron has cured those ills
did the niners make themselves better in
the draft
yes unfortunately they did i was uh
really rooting for the mac jones pick as
a seahawks fan
um i i i said this
you know it kind of hit me really a few
days later
that kyle shanahan's the most
devastating run game designer in
football and he's done all that without
a mobile quarterback without an extra
threat to change the numbers i am
terrified at the
concoctions you know the the nightmarish
scenarios every linebacker in the league
saw that and
mentally screamed uh and it's you know
just wetting themselves at night
thinking about what shanahan and trey
lance are going to do
wedding themselves at night i think he
said mentally waiting okay
okay okay i didn't know if you could
control a little less graphic yeah
confirm that or not uh the tim tebow
situation
uh anybody apoplectic on the nfl live
set there
um yeah i i was not i tried to be very
clear about this not no one's angry okay
i'm not angry at tim tebow tim tebow can
pursue whatever dream he wants i'm still
making terrible paintings in the hopes
that you know that flies
down my path at some point i am angry
not angry but i'm critical of urban
meyer
this to me reeks of bad
management and we're talking about a guy
who's the primary concern around urban
meyers not whether he can coach football
it's whether he can manage an nfl team
he comes in he hires a strength coach
out of iowa chris doyle
who was you know left town because of
accusations of racist behavior
that backfires immediately and now he
pulls this stunt it just
feels like like running a college team
is like running a mom and pop right
whereas running an nfl team is like
being a ceo this feels like mom and pop
behavior and that's what put me off
yeah i'm with you on it i i but i i
don't know it's one of those
where he's tebow lives what three doors
down from urban
they have so much success together like
how does
how does urban say no to tim tebow
um he says i'm now running an nfl team
and you're 33 years old and you haven't
taken a snap
since 2012 when you know meenakans had
yet to do sports radio
like this is not well let's do role
playing here
you're you're urban
okay you wait you want to be tebow no no
i want to be urban
okay so hey hey coach um
i'm having a barbecue i'd love for you
to come by and i wanted to talk to you
about something um i'm
i i'm kind of thinking that uh not kind
of thinking
i want to come and play football i want
i want to play tight end for you
tim you're filling three you don't have
to call me coach anymore
a relationship will always be my coach
and you know that coach
i do know that i'm just trying to help
you um
you are incredibly successful you make a
bazillion dollars
to be an icon to many people you're on
television you're writing books
you don't want to block for my team
that's probably not going to win the afc
south pym you don't want to be mocked
because you've never caught a pass
before in the nfl or any level really i
mean
kim this is not really what you want it
sounds like you miss being part of a
team so why don't you come on as an
assistant
you can hang out in the locker room you
can give rousing pre-game
speeches um you know i will give you a
giveaway
coach coach hold my non-alcoholic beer
i'm going to take off my shirt
and i and i want you to see how jacked i
am
okay let me up my offer tim you're not
just an assistant
you're the get back coach use those guns
to hold me back on the sideline just
like we have in college just like sean
mcvay has
with that strength guy you can be that
guy for me and then you'll get a ton of
camera time too
but you know that i i work out harder
than anybody
the game means so much to me i'm going
to give you tebow time
all the time anytime you want it i'm
going to be there i can get you tickets
to a mets game i am going to be there
for you coach
i will never fail you and you know that
you know that after that speech that i
gave after a loss in college
i was never going to lose again i'm i'm
at a barbecue and i'm ready to run
through a wall right now coach
you had me until the mets game tim and
nobody wants to go to a match game
come on uh you're right all right uh hey
great to talk to you mina and uh play
nice with the guys there on the set
always thanks dan thank you mina that's
mina kimes nfl analyst senior writer
podcast host
tv contributor yeah